hello and welcome to today's webinar i'm
anita ramanan
i'm a quantum software engineer working
in microsoft's quantum computing group
um and i'm here today to talk to you
about harnessing the problem solving
power
of quantum computing now my background
is i i studied a master's in atomic and
particle physics and physical chemistry
back in
at ucl and after that i immediately
joined microsoft as a graduate and have
been focusing more on software
engineering ever since
in the last kind of year and a half or
so i've been working quite closely with
the quantum team
and and in october last year i
officially joined as a quantum software
engineer
and have been working on something
called quantum inspired optimization
methods ever since today i'd like to
talk to you
about what microsoft is doing in the
quantum computing space you know why
why would we care you know what can we
use a quantum computer to solve
i'd also like to quickly look through
how you build a quantum computer
what we're doing in that space as well
as introducing azure quantum
and our quantum development kit i'll
that's been the second half of the talk
introducing how you would go about
coding up a quantum algorithm called
grover search algorithm
using q sharp in our content development
kit
first things first we need a reason to
do all of this why
would you want to build a quantum
computer now the answer to that question
is
much more varied than what we see on the
on the screen right now
but these are the kind of four areas
that we at microsoft are really focused
on solving with a quantum computer
let's start with simulation this this
involves taking
problems that are too complex for us to
solve analytically
using a classical machine and using a
quantum computer
to solve them instead for example
simulations that involve
uh elements that sit in the transition
metals or the lanthanides and actinides
these are involve the electrons in these
elements
exist in orbitals that are very very
closely packed relative to
some of the kind of simpler metals for
example
and therefore we need to be able to take
into account the coulombic interactions
between these electrons in order to
sufficiently simulate these things we
can't use approximations such as density
functional theorem
now to simulate these coulombic forces
it
requires a quantum stimulation and this
is beyond
our ability to act accurately do on a
classical machine
we need something like a quantum
computer to be able to attack these
problems we think
this can be the results of this can be
wide-ranging everything from
designing say better catalysts to
tackling world hunger or our climate
change by
designing fertilizers that work or that
we can produce more efficiently
or sorry designing ways in which we can
produce fertilizers more efficiently
cyber security is a second focus for us
you may have heard
of this you know this kind of upcoming
apocalypse where
rsa encryption is going to be broken by
quantum computers
but it's it's not quite as dire as it
sounds
yes quantum computers will be able to
exponentially
more efficiently factorize large numbers
down into their
prime factors which is the core of what
an rsa
encryption algorithm uses to secure our
data
now whilst a classical machine would
take something like
a billion years to actually brute force
an rsa2048 key
a quantum computer could do this in
about 100 seconds in theory
which is a problem for you if you know
your secrets are important for more than
100 seconds at a time
fortunately for us there are ways of
both
encrypting information um using quantum
computers so for example quantum key
distribution
um can be used to uh to exchange
cryptographic keys or we can actually
just
encrypt our information classically but
in a way that doesn't rely on this fact
that
breaking i'm sorry factorizing large
numbers is very difficult for a
classical
machine we use ways that are resilient
to quantum attack in the future
but that we can do classically this is
called
quantum um sorry post quantum
cryptography
um and if you're curious about it we
have a whole research team who is very
focused on developing new methods to do
this
and if you just search uh microsoft post
quantum
cryptography uh you'll be able to find
the the site and all the relevant
literature
optimization is another area that we're
looking at right now
now i mentioned briefly that this is
what i'm focused on so this is a kind of
area where we take
a quantum algorithm that's designed for
optimization
usually at the core of which lies a
quantum random walk
and what we do is we de-quantize it we
take out that quantum random walk and
replace it with a classical random walk
now we can implement this on a classical
machine using classical coding languages
like c
or c plus or python and we're actually
seeing speed up
over some of the best-in-class
traditional methods the classical
methods today
for example we're working with case
western reserve university
to optimize the way that they generate
pulse sequences for mri scans
now working with them we've actually
been able to
reduce by two-thirds the amount of time
that it takes to do
an mri scan we're also working on
traffic congestion problems for example
taking large number of cars traveling at
rush hour giving them a number of
different options for the routes that
they could take
and then optimizing to minimize either
the global congestion across this system
or the amount of time that they take to
get to the destination
or a number of other factors that we can
bring into this problem
so these are results that we can see now
today and then accelerate further
when a real kind of at scale quantum
computer is available
when we can unsubstitute that quantum
random walk
so we can get another speed up there
the last example up on the board is
machine learning
now this is a very new field of research
quantum machine learning is
as you might guess a quite exciting
field of study
the the problem is that it's very
uh costly to transform classical
information
into a format that the content computer
is able to
deal with so instead of taking you know
kind of a big data problem and then
doing these kind of machine learning
algorithms wholesale on them in a
computer
potentially we can be looking at
problems where there's a smaller
small input a small output and large
compute in the middle so we can apply
quantum computing for specific parts of
a machine learning problem
this is to say is obviously a fairly new
area of research
so it's one to keep an eye out on
what makes quantum computers any
different to a classical machine you
know i'm talking about these things that
we're not
physically able to do in a classical
machine and probably will never be able
to do
but why would a quantum computer be any
better at it
fundamentally comes down to a few kind
of quantum phenomena
the first one of which is superposition
and this is the one we'll be focusing on
today
now on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see a representation of the
classical bit the binary digit the
fundamental unit of digital information
a bit can be either zero off or one on
like the light bulbs and the two left
hand side light bulbs
it can't be anything else a quantum bit
or qubit on the other hand can be both
zero
and one at the same time as the kind of
colloquialism goes
you can kind of think of it more like
this dimmer switch it can be in a
probabilistic superposition
of both zero and one most importantly we
can use
this qubit in superposition in
combination with a bunch of other qubits
and manipulate the probability that when
we take a measurement to collapse the
superposition and give us either a zero
or a one out of the other end we can
manipulate the probabilities that we
actually see either of those results
and that's one of the key differences
something that we can't do on a
classical machine
we do tend to use this this kind of maze
analogy to kind of help us understand a
bit more about
how we can leverage this superposition
this is actually an analogy for the
grover search algorithm which is what
i'll be talking about uh in the second
half of this presentation
but effectively what we have here is we
have say a database of all of the
different ways
in which we could travel this maze and
classically
we're you know it's unsorted we have no
idea where to start
we're limited to just trying different
options one at a time until we arrive at
the correct solution
the right way through the maze as you
might imagine that's not particularly
efficient
we could get really lucky um we could
you know find it on our very first go
but we could get really unlucky either
and and find it on our very last
either way it scales with the size of
the problem
of the order of n n being the size of
what happens if we do this on a quantum
computer in this
instance what we do is we take all of
the possible routes that we could take
these kind of
items in our database each one
representing a solution
and we put them into a superposition
altogether
we can then manipulate whilst in the
superposition the probability amplitudes
of each of these different paths
we manipulate them we make it more
likely that when we measure we'll see
the correct one
and again we boost that probability
amplitude
until finally we take a measurement and
collapse that superposition down
and at this point if the probability
amplitudes are represented by the
thickness of these lines
because the uh answer that we're
searching for is so much thicker
than the other lines the higher
probability amplitude
we're much more likely to see the answer
come out when we take that measurement
now this is still probabilistic you
would still have to repeat this a number
of times in order to be sure that this
is the answer that
you know you were looking to find but we
find that this is actually
of order of root n so it's a quadratic
speed up over the best case classical
how do we represent information like
this well with a classical bit it's
fairly straightforward it's either
a zero or it's a one at any one time
fairly simple kind of notation to
represent this this notion of
superposition we need a new way
of describing um this these states
this is where this notation comes in
this is known as bracket
notation invented by uh paul dirac
on the left-hand side we have psi psi is
in this kind of weird pointy bracket
that's just called a ket
it just represents a column vector
if that arrow was on the other side and
the side was in the middle here
it would be called a bra and it would
represent a row vector
they're just vectors so we have our two
basis vectors zero and one
exactly the same as we have classically
um and each of them is assigned
something called a probability amplitude
alpha and beta now these are a measure
of the oneness or the zeroness of the
state
the really important thing to know about
a probability amplitude
is that unlike a classical probability
which must be a
positive number a probability amplitude
can be negative it can be complex
it can of course also be a positive
number but because of this this
nuance the fact that we can have
negative probability amplitudes and
complex ones
we're able to use them to interfere just
like waves we can constructively and
destructively interfere with these
uh probability probability amplitudes
whilst in superposition
and that's how we amplify that
possibility of seeing the answer
we're looking for
so we get the actual probability of
seeing a zero for example when we
measure
by taking the modulus of the probability
amplitude alpha
and squaring it likewise for for the one
state we do the same to beta
as with any other probability the
probabil the total probability of seeing
either the zero or the one
when we actually do that measurement has
to add up to one otherwise you've got
some third state which
the the it's not possible to get out of
that
of that superposition and you've broken
physics
so let's look at this in in action
so this is a quantum gate it's called
the hadamard gate
it just does it does an operation on on
a qubit on a single qubit
in this case we're going to feed it the
pure state psi
equals zero there's no superposition
here it's just in its zero state
and what we get out is a superposition
state
the hadamard gate is used to introduce
superposition
into our quantum system
this is an equal superposition both of
those probability amplitudes
are the same and if you um
take the modulus and square them you get
a half for each
uh different zero either for either zero
or one
says 50 50. what happens if we put one
through the same hadamard gate
this time we get a very similar one but
you'll notice that there's a minus sign
there
in front of the one part of this
equation
now experimentally this makes no
difference to us
if i took a measurement of of the first
state or the second state there
i would see you know with i would not be
able to tell that one had a negative
probability amplitude the reason being
that when you take the modulus and
square it both of them still give
a half so they're indistinguishable to
me by measurement
but we can use that minus sign to do
this interference which we were talking
about
now just as a heads up for later that
top state the
1 over root 2 0 plus 1 over root 2 1 is
known as the plus state
in shorthand and the lower one is known
as the minus state just to represent the
the change in sign there
we'll be using that later
so what happens if i take two of these
hadamard gates and jam them
uh one after the other and then apply
them to my zero state
might think that maybe we'll get
something kind of complicated out or
you know we'll get some still
combination of zero and one
but in fact what we see is that we get
out exactly what we put it
as long as we don't measure in the
middle
how does that work so let's say we start
in the zero state just
for the sake of argument let's describe
this like a probability tree
so at each level of this probability
tree we have equal probability
of measuring any of the states listed to
apply the first hadamard
gate and we get zero plus one with 50 50
uh likelihood of measuring either of
those
we then apply the second hadamard gate
again on the zero side of things we
had a zero plus one but when we put a
one into the hadamard gate if we
remember
uh from before we get a zero minus
one obviously we're ignoring the the one
over root twos here
just for simplicity's sake now
from here it's fairly straightforward to
see that the plus one and the minus one
are going to cancel out
that is an example of destructive
interference
and the two zeros will constructively
interfere which is why we end up with
just zero
if you're curious about what this looks
like mathematically this is it
now after the first hadamard we get this
plus state superposition like we expect
and then if you expand out the brackets
on the final state you find that we get
a half one minus a half one
gives us just the zero state
and that is how we use interference
okay so i've spoken a little bit about
what makes a quantum computer special
how do we actually go about building one
of these machines
there are a number of different ways in
which to approach this problem
the first one the kind of most common
way is to find some sort of quantum
system
one that can have a a two uh
kind of a two-state system so for
example if you take an electron
an electron can either be spin up or
spin down we've got a two-state system
great we can use that for computation we
can represent say
one as upstate and zero as downstate
fairly straightforward
we also need to be able to manipulate
that to use say laser pulses for example
to
excite these uh electrons or whatever
other quantum system we're using
and put them into superpositions and to
perform computation
now this is you know you'll hear things
about ion trap
qubits or superconducting qubits or
other kind of various different types
using these kind of the the kind of
local properties of these quantum
particles and these are known as noisy
intermediate scale
quantum devices nisk devices the reason
for the word noisy there
is that these these particles are
incredibly susceptible to noise from
from the environment that could be
anything from um
you know the the the environment heating
up a little bit you can never cool
anything down to absolute zero so there
will always be temperature
or some heat in the environment it could
be something like
a cosmic ray that you're just not able
to shield your your experiment from
it doesn't matter what the source of the
noise is the problem is that any
interaction with that particle
counts as a measurement on that particle
and it will ruin any nice kind of
quantum
state that you've set up this is known
as decoherence i.e
the loss of this nice coherent quantum
state that we want to use for compute
so how do we protect from this there's a
lot of research being done into this as
you might imagine
um one way to do it is to invent a
better qubit a cubit that is
more stable by default the other way
is to apply something called quantum
error correction which means that we
just have a bunch of
spare qubits effectively which are there
to detect and fix
errors when they're detected in a single
qubit and this combination of error
correcting
qubits and the actual you know cubit
you're trying to correct
is called a logical cubit so at the
minute we need
something of the order of a thousand uh
error correction qubits to make up
a single logical cubit the problem here
being that as you add more
logical qubits obviously the amount of
error correction qubits and
everything kind of scales out quite
rapidly and that introduces more noise
which introduces
more error which is a bit of a problem
so microsoft we decided okay cool so
error correction is is clearly
a useful thing to to pursue but instead
of you know building ion traps or
superconducting qubits
let's see if we can focus on something
that
should be inherently more stable
so we started looking at this thing
called a majorana fermion
now this was proposed by michael
friedman as a field manning
medal-winning mathematician about 20
years ago he said well
instead of using the local properties of
these quantum particles
why don't we use the topological
properties of a group of particles
instead
so we kind of you know did some research
we've
chosen the majorana fermion um
and this is what we're trying to use uh
for computation to represent our qubits
how does that work so what we do
is we take a nanowire and we put it in
something called the dilution
refrigerator you might have seen these
kind of big giant
golden chandelier looking things and
what this does is it takes materials
from kind of room temperature at the top
through a liquid nitrogen temperature at
77 kelvin
liquid helium at four and then it cycles
two phases of liquid helium
to get us all the way down to 15
millikelvin
now this is pretty much the coldest
place in the universe it's colder than
deep space
it is to put it into perspective at
somewhere very close to minus 273
degrees celsius
pretty cold now when you put these wires
at this temperature
the electrons in the material start
behaving weirdly
you start forming these these kind of
chains of electrons
with a half electron kind of imaginary
half an electron cap
on each end and we can manipulate these
strings
we can braid them together and this
braiding is how we represent
our quantum operations now we can bring
the ends of this
together and the two electron halves
will either
annihilate to produce no electron or
combine to produce
an electron and that is our zero and our
one so that's how we do measurement
but because they're physically separated
because we're using this topological
property
these braids like you can see here
we're much more resistant to noise so if
you can kind of imagine like time being
along the the vertical axis there and
these being our fermions we're doing a
whole sequence of operations by braiding
now on the right hand side you see a
situation where we had some noise enter
the system
the braids the the you know they're
they're wiggly they're not these kind of
nice pretty
um states anymore but just like if you
know i i got a bunch of strings and tied
them together and then shook
the knot around the information encoded
in that knot would still remain there
this is a similar idea here the
information encoded in this braid
pattern remains the same we don't lose
it
if there is perturbance to a point of
course
the other thing that we're uh focused on
at microsoft
is cryo control so not only do we need
to build
these these kind of you know uh stable
qubits
these topological qubits but we also
need to define
our design control hardware that's
capable of actually
working at cryogenic temperatures um and
controlling sending information and
and uh control to these um these these
quantum
particles so
our sydney team recently had a
breakthrough around this they
have invented a new way to control these
qubits using
up to 50 000 qubits using only three
control wires which are the kind of blue
wire so you can see exiting at the
bottom
right there now on the far right there
you can see the actual cryo control chip
it's the kind of top part
of that um that chip and then in the
kind of middle section that navy part
you can see six qubits embedded
and we can control theoretically up to
50 000
using just these three wires now this is
important
for two reasons one the more wires you
have
the more noise you're going to introduce
your system and two
there's only physically so much space
you can actually attach
wires to your chip right like if you
need 10 wires per chip
or sorry per qubit to um
to control the qubit you're going to run
out of space very quickly just
physically so it kind of limits your
scale so this should enable us to scale
much more effectively in the future
this brings us on to azure quantum so
this
brings all of our quantum efforts into a
single place
it brings our quantum solutions that
we're developing and deploying today
with customers those quantum inspired
optimization solutions
plus some quantum inspired kind of more
generic solvers
these are in pre-private preview right
now but there'll be a link later on
um in the slides so that you can sign up
for private preview when it's available
uh to azure quantum in general i might
add
it also brings our quantum software
efforts into one place so this is our
quantum development kit
all of the simulators all of the
resource estimation tools that we've
we've made available all of that's
available through azure quantum
also it's all open sourced on github if
you are curious
this also brings our quantum hardware
efforts into one place
our work on cryo control our work on the
topological qubit
and not just our qubits we're actually
partnering with a number of different
hardware
partners such as honeywell and ion q who
are manufacturing ion trap quantum
computers
and qci who are manufacturing
superconducting qubits
so you'll be able to with a single line
of code change
actually run q sharp our quantum
language
uh algorithms unreal hardware of various
different types
so i've mentioned the quantum
development kit a couple times
what do i actually mean by that
it's comprised of a few different parts
the first part is is the code
so much like with a machine learning
algorithm where you have a kind of
core piece that's the cpu runs on cpu
so you know the kind of basic io and all
of the kind of
data prep and things like that and then
you call out to
a gpu to accelerate where it'll actually
provide a speed up
whilst theoretically you could run
everything on the gpu it would be
expensive and a pain to code and
i mean cpus are pretty good at a lot of
things you know we spent a great many
years optimizing them
you can think of quantum programs in the
same way
we have q sharp code which runs on the
actual quantum hardware
but we have also driver code which is
written in a classical language such as
c-sharp or
python you can run it in a jupyter
notebook
and that does the kind of data prep and
the io
and the visualization etc and then again
calls the q sharp on that quantum
hardware when you will actually get
speed up from it
the quantum development kit also
contains a large number of uh
of kind of useful functions that are
contained in libraries
we have things like there's a numerix
library a chemistry library which is
quite handy
as well as lots of useful functions so
for example instead of having to
implement the quantum fourier transform
every time you need it which is quite
frequently
you can just call the qft operator
from the quantum the qtk libraries
it's very handy
we then have obviously unfortunately
there's no real quantum hardware
available
at scale yet so instead we need to run
things
on classical simulators this is where
the classical runtime comes in
so you can use the full state simulator
which basically mathematically simulates
the
state of all of the qubits in your
system unfortunately this is is kind of
ram bound memory bound um on a laptop
with about 16 gigs of ram you can
run up to 30 qubits depending on what
else you've got running
um if you know to run
ev every time you add another qubit you
double the amount of info
of ram that you need to store all the
information uh so
once you get to you know 40 qubits you
start needing
16 terabytes of ram 50 needs something
like 16 petabytes
at which point you're kind of reaching
the limit of the biggest supercomputers
that we have built to date so
possibly not going to get much further
than 50.
we also have to get around this problem
uh a couple of other different
simulators that can simulate larger
number of qubits by
kind of cheating effectively the trace
simulator for example instead of
simulating that
uh you know all of the different quantum
states that could exist in superposition
relies on you to provide it with
measurement
probabilities which means that it
doesn't need to deal with that kind of
level of simulation
but does allow you to simulate many many
more qubits
in order to kind of benchmark and test
your your algorithms
the toefl simulator limits you to a
specific subset of gates
and similarly allows you to to kind of
debug programs and optimize them
the resource estimator is actually in
use by our teams right now
this is allowing us to understand how
our quantum algorithms scale
with the problem size and optimize them
so that we'll be able to run them on the
smallest possible hardware set that
you know that is available at the um
whenever it comes
into kind of commercial use
then of course when a real quantum
computer is available we want to easily
be able to switch between the simulator
code and the
you know code that runs in a real
quantum machine that's very
straightforward with q sharp
all you do is you change the target it's
a single line of code
you say instead of you know i'm
targeting online simulator you'll target
ion cue
and that's all you need to do all that
needs to be done on the kind of
backend side is a compiler needs to be
written for that particular hardware
but your q sharp can stay the same now i
mentioned that this is all
open source earlier but it's also
available for
mac linux pc
windows even for free you can download
the simulators you can download qdk
and go and have have an explorer i'll
have some links at the end of the
deck as well
so before we get uh started with the
grow research algorithm walkthrough
we're gonna need four quantum operators
four gates
the first one is hope should hopefully
be kind of familiar if you've ever done
any kind of classical computer science
uh this is the not gate the x gate all
it does is it takes a qubit that is in
the state zero
and it flips it to one takes a cube
that's in state one
and flips it to zero it just flips the
the state of the cube it's
super straightforward the z-gate
is a little more quantum the z-gate does
nothing
to a zero or a state that you put in
when it's at zero
but it applies a minus one phase
when you pass it in a one state it'll be
important for a few
uh uh operations in a minute the
hadamard gate we've already seen this
one
takes the zero state to the plus state
and likewise or alternatively takes the
one state
to the what we call the minus state as
you can see we kind of expanded version
on the slide
and the last one is measurement so it's
not
strictly a quantum kind of operator in
the same way as the other ones are
but effectively this is you know what we
do when we take this measurement
and what we get out is a classical bit
per
qubit that we we measured so we either
get a zero or a one result out
let's get to using these firstly let's
introduce grover search
kind of spoke a bit about this earlier
the problem set up is
we have a database we have n elements in
that database
we know that we want to find one of
those we know what that one is
but it's unordered so you know we have
no kind of efficient classical way of
doing that other than this kind of
force method
what we do is we need little n qubits so
to represent say eight bits of
information
we need three qubits because two to the
power of three
is eight and we can hold two to the
power of three pieces of information
with three qubits
or bits of information sorry
so in this instance we're going to have
small n being three because
just for simplicity say for the
demonstration but obviously this could
scale up to a much bigger
problem size um
and what we're going to do is we'll
start with all of our qubits in this
nice
zero state everything is zero so that we
know kind of it's a good
known starting state so we can start our
computation
the very first thing we're going to do
is we will prepare our states
for search now this is just using the
hadamard gate which we've seen a couple
times already
so we apply the hadamard gate to the
zero
state that we start with to get the plus
state this gives us a one over root two
zero plus one as we saw previously
what happens if we apply that to a
larger system
it's fairly kind of logically we get if
you if you apply the hadamard n times to
n qubits you get n pluses
and then you can see the expansion there
on the right hand side
in our case we're just limiting this to
three so this simplifies down a bit
so we get plus plus plus and then if you
expand that out
you wind up with this equation so 1 over
root 8.
i'm not going to read all of those out
but you get the idea we have eight
different states that this could
possibly exist in
sometimes you might see these states
represented as instead of in their kind
of binary format
as this decimal representation where you
have zero one two
it's the same thing it's just written
differently because we're lazy
um so i'm going to be using these this
kind of graph to represent what the
probability amplitudes of
the states that we're looking at look
like throughout these manipulations
so initially we start with this nice
uniform superposition which is what
we've just done with the hadamard gate
if i took a measurement at this point i
would be equally likely to see
any of the states any of these eight
states that's not hugely useful
what does that look like in code so this
is what an operation looks like
in q sharp we define an operation using
the operation keyword here
this is the the input so this is going
to take something that we're going to
call database register
which is a qubit array if we wanted this
to uh just take in a single qubit rather
than an array
all we'd need to do is get rid of those
uh square brackets
but in this case we have a register with
multiple qubits
hence the square bracket
this here after the um
uh code or coden is this unit
is the return type unit in q sharp you
can kind of think of like void it
doesn't return anything
it just does stuff to the the qubits
then this this highlighted part is adj
and ctl this is an important one
this flags to the compiler that this
operation
is adjointable and controllable what do
we mean by those
basically means that so the adjoint of
an operation you can kind of think of
as it's it's kind of reverse right so
hadamard happens to be self adjoined
that means that
it is its own a joint so you do had a
mark twice and as we saw earlier
if you put zero and you do have two
hadamards you get zero out
but that's not necessarily the case for
other operators so if you define your
own custom operation here
you can do a bunch of different things
within it and that might not be
self-adjoint
if you just use these these flags here
um and don't specify an adjoint in the
actual body of this operation
the compiler will actually figure it out
for you it will automatically
create a and a joint version
and if you call that later on in the
code using this functor here
um it will just use that particular
auto-generated version if you happen to
have a more efficient version of this
yourself
or a particular preferred way of doing
it you're absolutely free to implement
your own
you would just add there would just be
more in the operation body down here
where you specify the adjoint now the
control version
a control gate like a controlled not
gate for example
uh will only apply the operation
that is being controlled if the control
qubits are all
in the one state so say for example we
had
our three qubits um and they're in state
zero
zero zero and these are our control
qubits
nothing will happen if we wanted to do
control on this qubit
using these two as the control so this
is the target
this on the other hand both of our
control qubits are in one state
and therefore we will have an effect on
the target qubit let's say we're to
control
x we could do this for example it would
now go to one one one
fairly straightforward and we do that
by applying the controlled functor so
here are the control qubits that has to
be a cubit array
if you just have a single qubit you can
just stick square brackets on the
outside of it and that turns it into an
array
and this is our target qubits
the actual part where we're applying the
hadamard to each of our
qubits we have this convenient applied
to each
method from q sharp now normally we
would need to
say hadamard qubit 1 qubit 2 etc
this allows us to just specify an
operation to apply and the
selection of qubits to apply to in an
array
um and just automatic it does it for us
automatically without having to write
loads of for loops
it's quite convenient so this is the
state that we find ourselves in this
nice uniform superposition
the next thing we want to do is
selectively apply a phase shift to the
element that we want to find this is our
marked element
in this case we've just arbitrarily
chosen it to be 0 1
0 our two state
now it's important to note that
even in this configuration if i took a
measurement
i'm still equally likely to see any of
these states
because as we saw before the probability
amplitude being negative
i can't measure that i have no way of
telling
it's the magnitude of that amplitude or
that probability amplitude
that is the important part for the
measurement so i still not really
achieved anything much here
but how do we do it it's a kind of first
important step
so what we want to do is we want to be
able to reflect
about the 0 1 0 state in order to
produce that minus sign in the phase
how do we do that well hopefully me
mentioning the minus sign
should remind you of that z operator we
introduced
if you recall z applied to 0 gives us 0
doesn't do anything but z applied to the
one state
gives us -1 it has this minus phase
oops and that's exactly what we're
looking to do here
so how do we apply this to multiple
qubits using that controlled functor
that we uh
found out about just a little bit
earlier so in this case we're going to
do ctrl
z on so
as we discussed we've got three qubits
control will only activate if the first
two qubits are in the state one
there's only two configurations where
that happens we've got one one
zero and one one
one so in this case these are our
control and these this is our target
qubit
so in the first instance control
activates because these two are in state
one
but because we're applying the z
operation nothing happens because z
applied to 0 gives us
0. so we end up with 1 1
0 just like we started
in the second case however our control
again activates because of the first two
being in one but this time we're
applying the z gate to a one state which
gives us that minus one phase
we end up with minus one one one
this is the phase shift we're looking
for great
so all we need to do to apply a phase
shift selectively
is to find a way to manipulate our
current face change the
our current state to change the basis
into one one
one apply the control z and then undo
that operation to give us back
our original uh state
so if you recall our marked state the
one we're looking for is zero one zero
the first thing we want to do is a turn
it into 1 1 1 so we can do that
ctrl z operation this is where the x
operator comes in
so if you remember x applied to 0 just
flips
gives us 1. and x applied to one
gives us zero so we're going to use this
on the first and the last qubit in our
register
so i'm just going to call this reg as
shorthand
so in c sharp or q sharp sorry what this
looks like
is x applied
to reg 0 0 being the index of the first
element
of the register and then we're going to
do x
applied to reg two
which is the third and this brings us
to one one one now the important thing
to note
is that this only brings us to the one
one one state
if our current state the the one that
we're looking
at is zero one zero in all other cases
it gives us some other
uh combination of zeros and ones but not
the all one state
the next thing we do is of course apply
our control z
how do we do that in c sharp or q sharp
we use the controlled functor
we just specify the gate so ctrl z
we now need to specify our control
qubits so those are the first
two uh qubits in the array so that's
zero
and one so this is one way of slicing
an array in q sharp you say the start
element
dot dot just means we're going up in
steps of one as the default
you can specify a different step if you
if you decide
and then we're stopping at one so all
this is going to do is give us zero and
one
the first and second elements and then
we specify the target
which is going to be oops register two
always with a semicolon so this is going
to take us
from our one one one state
to our minus one one state
right we've applied the phase shift but
now
we've applied a phase shift to a 1 1 1
state whereas the marked element that we
want is obviously 0 1
0. so we need to undo those two x
operations from before and now we go x
reg 2
and then x reg
zero
and that brings us from minus one one
one
to minus zero one zero
and thus we have applied a phase change
only to the marked element the one that
we're looking to
to measure out at the end of this
fantastic
now we're actually going to use this
trick another time a bit later on in
grover's algorithm
and in this case we don't want to
reflect about the march state
we want to reflect about the start state
that uniform superposition
all pluses so in this instance
we want to take plus plus plus
and turn it to this
how do we do that first things first we
need to generate the all one state just
like we did
if you hopefully remember hadamard we'll
take
plus to zero so what first thing we're
going to do
is we're going to use apply to each
in q sharp we're going to say we want to
apply the hadamard
to each of the qubits in our register
that's going to take us from plus plus
plus
zero zero zero great
then what we want to do is turn that to
one on ones so again we use apply to
each
hopefully you're getting a kind of
inkling of what's going going on here
now
we use x
that will take us from zero zero zero
to one one one great
now again we we apply the control z
and then we undo the the previous two
apply to eaches
which will take us back to
plus plus plus but now with a minus
phase exactly the same trick it's called
changing the basis
and it's really useful for kind of other
operations and
and things later on
and this is what that looks like in in
in q sharp so we've already seen this
um one useful thing to note with q sharp
is
we can use this message operator this
allows us to write things out to
consoles so that we can for example
in this case understand what we're doing
where we are in the algorithm as we're
printing out results we then do this
familiar
application of our two x's to the first
and the last elements of our database
register
this brings us to our one one one state
we then applied our controlled zed this
is the control function functor like we
saw earlier
we can use this syntax now as well so i
i introduced this way of of
um referring to a slice of a database
but
because taking all but one um of a
all but the last uh element of a qubit
register is such a complica a common
um thing to want to do in a quantum
algorithm
q sharp has it for you so if you say
most that will take
all of the elements of a qubit array
other than the last one
and if you do tail it just takes the
last element of an array
that's kind of handy but it's equivalent
to these two representations which i
showed previously
up to you now you might be curious as to
what this within apply thing is doing
so this is a within apply block um
what it does is it does whatever is in
the within
block first so those two x's take us to
one one one
then it does what's in the apply block
the ctrl z to take us to -111
and then it undoes whatever was in the
within block it does the join
which takes us back to our minus zero
one zero which is exactly what we want
fantastic
which leaves us with this again if i
take a measurement now
i'm equally likely to see any of those
qubit states
but we've applied a phase shift
the next thing we want to do is reflect
about the start state that plus plus
plus
this is what we saw in the when i was
writing in one note earlier
so what we do is we take these delta so
this is
the delta between the average amplitude
and the
magnitude of the probability amplitudes
and we reflect didn't we couldn't figure
out how to do a rotation
animation there but this is what we get
now if i take a measurement i am much
more likely
to see the kind of heavily uh increased
uh well i'm much more likely to see the
zero one zero state because of that
heavily uh magnified probability
amplitude for the marked state zero one
zero
and i'm much less likely to measure any
of the other states
fantastic so we've already walked
through this
in in kind of writing what does this
look like in q sharp
again we're making use of this handy
within apply so that we can do
uh the operation the control z and then
undo that preparation of the all one
state the first thing we do is we
apply the hadamard again to take us from
all plus to all zero
then we apply x to each qubit in the
register to take us from all zero to
one control z again using this most
terminology or you can use the the
slices like i showed previously
and then we undo those two uh the
application the x and the hadamard to
bring us back to the uniform
superposition which we started with
fantastic which leaves us with this
now putting this all together what we
want to do is actually
instead of just doing this once we want
to do it many times so that
it's very very unlikely that we'll ever
measure anything
other than the marked state of course
still a possibility
but very small possibility
so what we do is we repeat this we use
uh we have to repeat those two rotations
of the order of
root n times in this case we have n
being the number of elements in our
database
in this case eight so we're going to
repeat it twice
so in this case any iterations is two
this is a for loop much like you will
see in any other coding language so we
say for index
in zero to
the number of iterations we specified
minus one so we don't
end up having one too many we're going
to do our two reflection steps reflect
about marked then reflect about uniform
twice in this case and then
we're going to return the result of this
for each statement
now the for each is another kind of
useful q sharp feature
what it does is it applies whatever we
put in the first argument
to all of the qubits in a register that
we pass in as an array
in this case it's going to do m reset z
now what that does is it takes a
measurement of a
of a qubit and superposition or a set of
qubits in this case
oh well sorry it does it one by one
um and returns us a zero or a one result
um it then the reset z part
sets that qubit back to our nice
starting state of zero
in order to have it be ready for use by
another part
of the program later
this using statement is um
key to this so this this allocates us
some qubits for use within that using
block much like you might have seen in c
sharp
um and then it it requires that we
return those qubits in that zero state
so that it's ready for uh reuse later
now you'll notice here that the uh
the return type here isn't unit as
before it's actually got a return type
of result
a result array in this case that's just
going to be the array of results that we
read out from
emery said said here that we're
returning
so to summarize we've prepared our
states for search
we by doing the hadamard uh on all of
the qubits in the array
in the in the register we selectively
apply
the phase shift just to the marked
element 0 1
0 by reflecting about the marked state
by that trick of basis changing
we then invert about the average which
we do by reflecting about the start
state of plus plus plus again using that
trick
then we repeat those two steps a bunch
of times twice in this instance but
more if you had a bigger database
and then we take a measurement and see
what we get out which is hopefully
the marked element let's see that
in action
so here we are in visual studio
uh this is the code that we have kind of
been looking at for the last
uh while so it should not be no surprise
to you at this point
this is the main point of entry to our
quantum program i've called it grow
research
what we haven't seen so far is what does
the classical driver code look like
and this is it so it's a c sharp i chose
to use in this case go to use python as
i said
um here we declare our number of qubits
and the number of grover iterations
of course this can be done
programmatically i chose to hard-code it
in this instance
just to simplify the demo but of course
in
in practice this would be um flexible
uh this is the key line that this is the
single line of code that we would need
to change
in order to run you know either on the
simulator or unreal hardware or on a
resource estimator so
in this case we've chosen to run it
locally on my machine using the quantum
simulator
but we could just as easily have put say
a resource estimation
or estimator even to to see
it doesn't actually run the program but
it tests what resources would be needed
to run it
um alternatively we could have said say
ion q or honeywell hardware or qci and
that would run
in azure quantum when it's released of
course
so the single line of code is is is the
kind of key one
for for kind of benchmarking different
types of hardware and software
the next important line is this one
which of course runs
our quantum algorithm so it says grow
research which is what i call that q
sharp operation dot run i pass in the
simulator
the number of qubits and the number of
iterations
and then the dot result says just wait
for it to return something
um which is of result type
so i do that and then all we're doing is
printing this um
result that we get back out obviously we
could do something more sophisticated
but
it's just a demonstration in this case
ignore the red squiggly line um
my my visual studio is playing up it
actually is working
so now we're going to actually run it
it's running again on the simulator
we see you know we're stating what what
uh element we're searching for zero and
zero
you see that it's done two instances of
that grover iteration reflecting about
marked and then reflecting about the
start state
and out at the end comes zero one zero
the state that we're looking for that
march state
been a success great
in uh in a nutshell was it was grover
search algorithm
thank you very much uh for for joining
me today um if you are if you're curious
to learn more about quantum computing
i do encourage you to have a look at
these links uh the first one will give
you a bit more information about what's
available or what will be available on
azure quantum
and we'll allow you to sign up for the
private preview
uh there is comprehensive documentation
available
at docs.microsoft.com quantum this
includes a whole bunch of kind of basic
tutorial information
uh information on all the different
libraries available through q sharp
and obviously all of the kind of
documentation around q sharp itself
if you're interested in downloading the
content development kit that's available
on the third link that's again available
on mac linux windows
whatever it is you can run it install
free via like binder
from the github page directly actually
um and then if you're looking to you
know kind of maybe contribute to
the community to the uh open source q
sharp
libraries or the simulator or whatever
it is please go check out the github
link there the first one
i would really really recommend you
checking out the second one there the
quantum katas
these are a sequence of challenge-based
tutorials where it'll take you from you
know even the basics of kind of complex
arithmetic
all the way through to learning how to
write quantum algorithms
um in a kind of step-by-step way so it
kind of gets harder as you go along
really really solid resource would
definitely recommend checking it out
it's been an absolute pleasure speaking
to you today please don't forget that
we've got a live q a coming up now
so if you have any questions now's the
time to ask them
and with that i will say goodbye thank
you very much
hi everybody um thank you very much for
for joining us today
i really appreciate your your time um
now we're into the live q a portion
um so throughout the the session we've
received lots of really great questions
i tried to answer
a few in the uh text chat
um but i'll kind of pick out a couple of
the common ones for example
and uh try and answer as many as we can
and the uh one of the most common ones
that uh i've kind of
seen popping up in the chat so far has
been
as someone from a software developer
background or a kind of an engineering
background but not necessarily in
physics
how would i get started um
you know with this kind of content
confusing stuff you know how do i learn
to become a quantum software engineer
and uh my best suggestion for you would
be
um if you check out the the links in
that uh resources section that you can
see
on the um on the webinar platform
um there'll be some really good starting
state places for you to
start learning about this um i'd in
particular
uh like to draw attention to the
quantitative link
so these are kind of a challenge-based
tutorial
um kind of uh sequences
of problems effectively so you can kind
of um it's in a big jupiter notebook
and each little section has a couple of
questions and you can
type your your answers and then run the
the script
and it'll give you a hint if you get it
wrong for example
um and that starts from just learning
the very basics of complex mathematics
um all the way through to implementing
algorithms and kind of much more
complicated things
so i definitely recommend that i think
that's been uh for a lot of
we hire a lot of software engineers in
our in the quantum team um
not people with physics backgrounds and
a lot of them have said that
the cutters have been really really um
helpful
um the other side of it
um from a physics background um
i'd recommend learning you know kind of
learning uh
some kind of software engineering
principles like um
you know learning a language such as
c-sharp or or python
something object-oriented um that will
kind of get you started
with the more software engineering
aspects
personally i found the
[Music]
a book called the imposter's handbook
um a really good start kind of gives you
a a good
cover of the topics and software
engineering that you might not
know even exist um as someone from a
scientific
uh background so i'd recommend that um
from the other kind of side
of the of the fence
um i had a good question someone asked
so
um you say that these quantum computers
run
at almost zero kelvin um so we're
talking in the millikelvin range
um isn't that really expensive really
hard to do um
you know isn't that going to be really
energy-intensive
um and actually that's an interesting
question because
um yes to get something down to that
temperature from
temperature takes first of all of a long
time like that'll take a few days
um in the one of these kind of quantum
as we call them
a dilution refrigerator
but and then that that kind of part
takes takes a lot of energy
but once uh the system is actually
sitting at that temperature
unless you have a kind of catastrophic
leak somewhere in the system and you
lose all of your liquid helium
um it's actually relatively less little
energy to keep
your at that super low temperature um
um the other part of that question was
well
you know if if it requires all this
highly specialized hardware and it needs
to be kept at these super low
temperatures
will that mean that barely anyone's
going to have access
to teams and the answer to that question
is honestly most likely the model for
quantum computation or kind of
availability
will be like a cloud computing model for
example through microsoft
azure azure quantum um for example you
will have access to
much the same way as you can access uh
gpu machine
examples to do machine learning um
workloads
and you can kind of think of these these
quantum
machines as as co-processors in the same
way as
you would use a graphics processing unit
a gpu and a machine learning
um algorithm um
well on a quantum computer when it's
going to provide you with
um speed up now this is this doesn't
mean that we're going to
you know in in 20 years time we'll be
running um you know i'll be playing
uh pc games on on a quantum machine
um because just like with the gpu it
would be expensive and
honestly kind of a pain to code for it
when a class social machine is already
available
it's cheap it's highly optimized and the
quantum machine isn't going to give you
any particular speed up
so we're kind of going to move into the
future where we have these quantum and
classical co-processors
and we use each of them to their
strengths
um we also had a few questions around
the kind of cryptography angle um
something about that i think there was a
question about the impact on blockchain
so we have as i mentioned in the uh
webinar
um the a team that are looking
exclusively at
post quantum methods so i linked uh
their home page in the webinar chat so
you can hopefully
see that and kind of go investigate if
you're curious
there are also ways in which we can use
a quantum computer to exchange
information
um more securely so for example we can
exchange keys using something called
quantum key distribution
and due to some kind of fundamental
properties of a quantum computer um for
example
um we have uh
the quantum no cloning theorem this
means that
we cannot copy a stream of quantity we
can't
if someone was listening into your
communication channel
they wouldn't be able to copy that
and then kind of read out which means
that they have to be listening to your
unique channel of communication
um and because the the states that
you're sending to transfer your key
are quantum states any observation they
make will
cause measurements will cause errors in
the key that you actually uh get out at
the other end
so we can actually use these quantum
phenomena to
encrypt our information more uh securely
as well as to uh to crack things like
rsa so there's kind of multiple
ways of kind of approaching those
uh what else did we have um we had a few
people asking about what the kind of
biggest challenges of quantum computing
are
honestly the really big challenge right
now is as i kind of said in the webinar
um it's noise getting a system that is
sufficiently isolated
from the um from the surroundings that
uh don't interact very easily or just
inherently stable
will have long gait lifetimes this is
really
really hard to engineer there are some
really great leaps being made
with things like superconducting qubits
ion traps
systems as i mentioned earlier hopefully
topological qubits will also help us
uh tackle these issues but right now
it's
you know it's really the kind of key
thing that's preventing us from having
these machines available
at scale
another common question i saw in the
chat was
around quantum machine learning
so you know kind of how can we apply a
quantum computer to speed up a machine
learning algorithm now
as i again mentioned one of the bigger
problems here
is that trying to input big data into a
quantum machine
is not particularly efficient
it takes you know a lot of processing
time
to encode classical information into a
way that
um a a quantum computer can can kind of
deal with that data
um so the optimal kind of use case here
is we
use a quantum computer for accelerating
specific
parts of a machine learning pipeline
for example you kind of have a
hybrid approach where kind of some
computationally complex subroutines
that would actually benefit from quantum
speed up can be outsourced to one of
these quantum processors
and should also be able to
efficiently solve systems of linear
equations and perform
matrix inversions so those have
relatively uh small inputs and outputs
and we can also use actually what which
groover's
algorithm we can actually use that
amplitude amplification
um to more efficiently um
search a problem space for example
here's some examples most recently we
have released a
quantum machine learning library for q
sharp i linked that
in the q a chat so please do
have a look at that if you're curious to
learn more
um just going to read through some of
these new questions
actual and practical examples of content
of quantum computers okay um so
the the example that um i give most
frequently
is around the simulation of
kind of these as i mentioned at the very
beginning
of systems which have electrons that are
highly correlated
so for example nitrogenase nitrogenase
is a
it's an enzyme it is capable of taking
nitrogen and hydrogen at room
temperature and producing
ammonia now this is
significant because we need to produce
ammonia to
make fertilizer to to fertilize their
fields to grow crops to feed the human
population
at the minute the majority of this
ammonia is produced through something
called the harbor bosch process
which takes incredible amounts of
energy so they you have to run nitrogen
over
a catalyst at 400 degrees celsius and at
200 atmospheres of
pressure um
and uh that as you might imagine is not
a very uh efficient process in fact
it uses um you know something like one
or two percent of the global
uh energy production every single year
just to do this um
so if we can actually use this
nitrogenase enzyme to do this at room
temperature and pressure
um this could be huge it could have huge
impact for something like you know for
things like climate change or global
warming
um unfortunately because the active site
of nitrogenase
um includes a compound called simoco
which
includes um iron and molybdenum atoms
um we're unable to actually uh simulate
the
the electronic configuration there um to
high enough precision um
to actually kind of to produce at an
industrial scale
so this is an example of a concrete
application of a quantum of a quantum
computer
we have any pc simulation programs
that can actually help us to test our
code
yes the quantum development kit comes
bundled with a number of different
simulators
um these not only aim to simulate the
full quantum state
of all of the qubits in your quantum
algorithm that you need to use for your
particular
algorithm even but they also include
resource estimators
um and in fact our uh
our quantum research team our algorithms
research team
actually use the simulators and resource
estimators
davey to help us optimize our algorithms
so that they'll run on the smallest set
of hardware available which will mean
that we'll be able to run them
as soon as possible
so yes if you're if you're interested
you can absolutely run these you can run
them locally it all comes for free
you can get about 30 qubits to run on a
local machine if you have about 16 gigs
of ram and
so uh the web windows open using up all
of the
the ram on your your machine
uh i think we're probably
running out of time so i will answer
one more question um and then
we can wrap
[Music]
sorry i'm just reading through them um
right okay so this is a oh that's quite
specific
um
oh uh there's a question about
internships actually
um yes absolutely if you are engaged
in um quantum computing in quantum
uh in a physics degree or in a computer
science degree
maths degree uh these kinds of
backgrounds
um we actually have a summer internship
program
that runs every year we take candidates
from across these these disciplines we
usually have
both an engineering and a research
flavor to these uh internships
and during them you'd actually be
working directly alongside our quantum
research team
or the quantum solutions team or other
kind of members of the quantum product
group
uh to build solutions build new
algorithms
and to kind of you know further the
field as if you were just uh
you know one of the team um so i'd
absolutely encourage
um you to to have a look and to join us
for
for a summer we'd love to have you and
um yeah
please please feel free to uh to have a
look it'll be on the microsoft
career site or the microsoft research
career site um
you should be able to find us through a
web search
um all right well i think that's that's
uh all we have time for today
thank you so much for attending we
really appreciate your participation
and your interest uh in the subject
there have been some great questions
um if you are interested in learning
more please do check out
the resources that are linked this will
be made available
on demand you should get an email with
the link
once that's ready um and
i look forward to seeing what you can
contribute to the quantum computing
space in future
thank you very much